all right researchers at the  Massachusetts Institute of Technology  are making headlines for their small  army of robots those are what they call  these mini cheetah robots according to  MIT news the robots weigh about 20  pounds and researchers say they are  virtually indestructible  Tony de Cobo expect them to hit store  shelves anytime soon mit be a tool for  researchers research people people keep  saying they're cute they are not cute  when they're coming in your window at 3  a.m. like in the army imagine I know our  producer Danielle told me that they're  suppose they're really cute and I can  just imagine their eyes being red and  red attacking the pictures like here's  here's eight guys in all black with the  holding they have their power by 12  motors they reportedly have physical  intelligence they are our future carrier  reach your robot